Hi, I'm Luke.
>> And I'm Anthony.
>> And we're coaches here at Udacity.
When you're first learning to code,
both concepts and
tools are being presented
to you at the same time.
It can be hard to
understand the concepts.
If you aren't sure how to use the tools
you need to apply the concepts yourself.
>> In the next series of videos,
we're going to show you some tips for
setting up your workspace.
That will help you really make the most
of your Udacity learning experience.
And they'll be useful throughout your
entire life as a computer programmer.
>> That's right.
Next, we  'll talk with Mike,
a programmer with years of experience.
To find out why it's so important to
set up your workspace for development.